je
[Musique]
bonjour à tous vous avez des tâches et
vos ceintures j'espère vous n'êtes pas
été trop secouée par ses petits vols je
vous amène pas une solution pour
supprimer le petit singe la
procrastination quoique salle calmerait
bien je pense moi je suis là pour vous
parler plutôt de potentiel plus
précisément de la gestion du potentiel
et la performance à travers mon
expérience je vais vous expliquer
comment j'ai réussi à atteindre mon
objectif à savoir devenir champion du
monde de voltige à partir du moment où
j'ai cessé de vouloir l'être absolument
ans l'idée ce n'est pas de faire de vous
des as du mans je vous rassure
par contre je pense qu'ici vous avez
tous été au moins confronté une fois des
échéances importantes quelle qu'elle
soit un examen concours un projet peu
importe
et finalement ce qui peut s'appliquer
dans le cockpit d'un avion de voltige ou
même un avion de chasse
eh bien ça peut s'appliquer au quotidien
les images que vous avez vu en
introduction elle date du dernier
championnat du monde de voltige qui a eu
lieu en france à châteauroux un
championnat du monde de voltige ça se
passe comment ça dure une dizaine de
jours on y regroupe une soixantaine de
concurrents de différents pays et durant
ces dix jours on va effectuer entre
trois et quatre vols
donc c'est pas beaucoup sachant que ces
vols c'est ça dure une dizaine de
minutes dizaine de minutes donc
finalement on passe beaucoup de temps à
attendre donc faut vraiment géré latente
entre les vols et être capable sur dix
minutes vraiment l'état font ultra
concentré un vol c'est donc un programme
un programme c'est une dizaine de
figures qu'on va devoir réaliser un
petit peu comme au patinage artistique
ses rangs des figures codifié là on a un
petit exemple sur l'écran et on va
devoir réaliser ça au degré près vous
avez vu c'est assez précis les
trajectoires
on va être jugés par des juges
professionnels et comme au patinage
artistique on va devoir déplacer dans un
volume nous notre volume c'est un box
c'est un cube de 1 km de côté duquel on
doit éviter de sortir sinon on est
pénalisé on va évoluer là dedans avec
des véritables formules un désert ces
avions qui peuvent atteindre jusqu'à 400
km heure pour le petit calcul à 400 km
heure les 1 km en effet en six secondes
ce qui veut dire qu'en gros on est
vraiment dans la prise de décision très
rapide et en plus ça vous avez pu voir
les trajectoires sont très
serrés ce qui veut dire qu'on va prendre
énormément de facteurs de charge une
dizaine d'objets au maximum c'est-à-dire
subir dix fois le poids de notre corps
est donc tout ça en essayant d'avoir le
pilotage le plus précieux vous avez bien
compris que en plus des capacités
physiques au niveau cognitif on est
vraiment dans la restitution de
mouvements techniques rapides précis qui
doivent être faits parfaitement
on re pour vulgariser imaginer une
partie de tennis un match de tennis mais
en quatre jeux seulement quatre jeux
c'est pas beaucoup finalement par contre
on rajoute une règle c'est que vous ne
devez en théorie perdre aucune balle
pour espérer l'emporter sur l'adversaire
bah ça ça use parfaitement comment se
déroule une compétition de voltige sa
liste exactement aussi à quel point les
scores les écarts de points peuvent être
serré pour pouvoir espérer accéder au
podium
c'est pour ça qu'on dit en moyenne il
faut entre 8 et 10 ans de pratique à
haut niveau dans ce sport pour espérer
emporter un titre et c'est ce que met en
moyenne les pilotes pour le remporter
pour ma part j'ai réussi à remporter ce
titre de champion du monde lors de ma
première participation à un championnat
ce championnat ce qui n'avait jamais été
fait or comment je vais vous l'expliquer
je vais vous raconter un petit peu mon
histoire et je pense que finalement il
n'a pas mal d'entre vous qui vont s'y
retrouver
petit retour en arrière on revient au
début de la saison 2015 c'est ma
deuxième saison à haut niveau
en voltige je sors d'une première saison
qui est prometteuse continue les
résultats et de mon expérience et donc
du coup faut savoir qu'en voltige à au
niveau de la préparation c'est hormis la
préparation technique les vols après
c'est chacun fait un peu sa sauce moi je
me dis on est comme dans un sport de
haut niveau donc je vais me préparer
comme un sportif de haut niveau donc je
rajoute la préparation physique
préparation technique bien sûr les
stages entraînements les vols et un peu
d'initiation c'est la préparation
mentale peut être pas assez on verra par
la suite et donc j'aborde ma première
échéance qui le championnat de france
avec ces conditions le championnat de
france c'est certes un championnat
national mais c'est sûrement l'un des
plus relevé au monde tant le niveau en
france dans cette discipline est élevé
quand je débarque je suis pas forcément
le pilote qui a le plus d'expérience il
ya déjà des vieux briscards dans
l'équipe
par contre sûrement celui qui a été le
mieux préparé à cette échéance
et ça j'en ai conscience et dans ma tête
quand j arrive je me dis
ce qui faisait la jonction qu'on connaît
tous il faut qu' il faut que j'assure
faut que je gagne j'ai pas le droit de
perdre
je pense qu'on a tous connu ces petites
choses à certains moments face à des
échéances sur lequel on était attendu
ces petites injonction qui généralement
on nous rajoute surtout une bonne grosse
dose de pression avant avant de faire
l'examen est rarement ça nous aide pas
effectivement le résultat je vous laisse
deviner c'est pas du tout celui que
j'attendais je fais une troisième place
c'est un résultat qui est honorable mais
personnellement moi cette compétition
c'est vraiment un échec
je passe à côté mais vole je suis
nerveux stressé je termine la semaine je
suis complètement épuisé moralement et
nerveusement mois pour moi c'est
vraiment une déprime
à ce moment là la sensation que j'ai
c'est un sportif américain qui l'a
décrit très bien qui s'appelle nice au
beau c'est un joueur de foot
professionnel qui dit vous avez
économisé toute l'année pour vous
acheter la voiture de vos rêves vous
arrivez chez le concessionnaire et au
moment de payer vous avez juste pas le
code pin de votre carte bleue quoi c'est
un peu ça moi à ce moment là et j'ai
deux options je vois deux options je me
dis bah j'arrête la compétition parce
que je suis peut-être pas fait pour ça
je n'étais pas un compétiteur ou sinon
bah deuxième option je vais jusqu'au
bout de mes rêves jusqu'au bout de mon
rêve je m'accroche
par contre hors de question de revivre
une compétition dans ses talents je vais
choisir la deuxième option et je pense
que c'était la bonne
donc quelques semaines passent et
j'aborde la préparation des championnats
du monde et ce championnat vraiment dans
un autre état d'esprit beaucoup plus
focalisé finalement sur ce que j'ai à
accomplir c'est à dire mais vol sur le
présent sur la tâche à accomplir par
contre vraiment détaché de l'enjeu
j'oublie le résultat j'oublie finalement
ce rêve de devenir champion du monde je
me dis j'ai vraiment focalisé sur mes
vols et puis on verra bien effectivement
l'idée c'est vraiment de garder ce
mindset pour attaquer la compétition
c'est vraiment mon objectif est donc
j'aborde ce championnat sous premiers
championnats du monde auxquels je
participe dans cet état d'esprit je vous
rappelle juste le conteste à ce moment
là moi je suis quasiment inconnu du
monde de la voltige à part au niveau
national je suis inconnu des juges
ça reste un sport jugé quand même et
pourtant je vais faire mon premier vol
et là il ya un déclic
je remporte premier programme dans un
championnat du monde premier vol et bien
je remporte le programme donc je prends
la tête du classement général devant
tout le monde comme ça c'est qui lui
bonjour sauf qu'à ce moment là
moi je suis vraiment détaché de l'an je
suis vraiment content de ma performance
mais détaché de l'enjeu du résultat je
me dis je garde ce état d'esprit et puis
on verra bien et rebelote deuxième
programme et je réitère la même chose je
gagne ce programme ce qui me permet de
prendre une avance considérable au
classement général par contre
parallèlement à ce moment là bas je
commence à être un petit peu rattrapé
par l'enjeu on a beau se dire c'est bon
on le prend poule on voit ce qui est en
train de se passer est effectivement un
troisième vol ça va être un petit peu
plus compliqué vole un peu plus
difficile mais je m'accroche tient bon
et je reste devant et là on arrive à
laver du quatrième programme alors par
contre là je suis pleinement rattrapée
par l'enjeu
je vous garantis que la nuit d'avant les
quasiment blanche pourquoi parce que à
ce moment là je suis en train de me
rends compte de la performance que je
suis sur le point de réaliser comme
juste sur le point c'est à dire que je
m' extrait du présent la tâche à
accomplir savoir fermer vos le plus
proprement possible et je suis déjà en
train de me projeter dans un avenir
hypothétique et la [ __ ] la machine à
cogiter à semer en marche
finalement c'est la météo qui va en
décider autrement
l'épreuve pas avoir lieu à cause du
mauvais temps donc bien c'est l'épreuve
se termine les championnats du monde se
termine et donc balas et le résultat je
remporte ce titre le rêve se réalise
voilà là on fait
en plus c'était à la maison en france
voilà c'est un bel événement est bon
quand on est sur le podium on est
vraiment on est vraiment content du
travail accompli
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
finalement par rapport à la compétition
précédente
c'est ce que je vais expliquer c'est à
dire qu'en fait je me suis détaché de
l'enjeu détacher du résultat
par contre je suis vraiment focalisé sur
la tâche à accomplir du moins au début
après il ya un moment où comme je vous
le dis on est quand même rattrapé un peu
par l'enjeu et c'est ce qui a permis de
faire la différence
moi quand je le décris je me dis bah
finalement j'ai réussi à lâcher prise à
lâcher prise sur ma compétition lâché
prise que ce que c'est et en quoi ça
peut nous concerner tous dans notre
quotidien
finalement quand on regarde notre
société c'est pas si éloigné que d'un
championnat du monde de voltige ou même
un championnat tout court on est notée
on est classé on évalué selon des
objectifs à atteindre
on se compare souvent les uns aux autres
et finalement depuis tout petit depuis
le plus jeune âge on est modelée pour
évaluer dans un milieu ultra compétitif
je suis pas en train de vous dire que la
compétition c'est pas bon je pense que
ça peut avoir certaines vertus notamment
de tirer un groupe vers le haut et comme
tout système lorsque c'est excessif ça
peut devenir nocifs pourquoi parce que
c'est anxiogène et incapacitant et
finalement au lieu de se consacrer sur
la tâche son travail à accomplir et se
dire que le résultat ça sera finalement
qu'une conséquence du travail qu'on va
faire sur le moment présent et ben
devient omnibulé par le résultat la note
et on le connaît on veut le classement
la note est finalement et ben ont déjà
on est déjà en train de se projeter dans
ce qui peut arriver on se fait des
scénarios est ce qui fait qu'au moment
d'agir au moment de ces là où on va
décider de ce qui va se passer
eh ben on commence à cogiter on est dans
ces injonctions s'auto jugeons s'auto
évaluer ce que je vais bien faire et ce
que je vais mal faire ainsi de suite en
gros tout ce qu'il faut pour bloquer son
potentiel et ses compétences et
finalement c'est comme ça que des fois
en étant le mieux préparé pour faire
face à un examen concours ou même peu
importe et bien on passe à côté on passe
à côté cet examen ce concours ce projet
même de la fille qu'on veut séduire
enfin voila c'est il ya plein d'exemples
et donc c'est là qu'intervient cette
notion de lâcher prise
alors effectivement les pros du
développement personnel dirais c'est un
vaste sujet c'est pas que ce que je vais
vous expliquer effectivement moi je vais
juste me concentrer sur la partie
on va dire dans l'action qu'on peut
finalement prendre du recul lâcher prise
aussi au moment d'agir finalement lâché
prise et je vais commencer par dire que
ce que ça n'est pas parce que attention
il faut pas se tromper lâcher prise
c'est pas de la passivité c'est pas de
la basicité je suis pas en train de vous
dire
j'arrive à mes championnats du monde
j'ai les bras un peu ballan bon bah
c'est bon j'y vais je vais lâcher prise
non pas du tout on n'est pas on n'est
pas là dedans déjà un préalable à tout
ça c'est être il faut être
il faut être focus ou être investis faut
être à ce qu'on fait c'est à dire si on
est pas dans l'action déjà c'est pas bon
les anglais vont dire un terme committed
engagé moi je dirais que c'est être pour
faire et pas faire pour être ça c'est
déjà la base et ensuite on va introduire
une notion une notion d' acceptation
c'est accepter qu'on peut pas tout
maîtriser
on ne peut pas forcément tous maîtrisés
dans son domaine ou en l'occurrence
quand je suis dans un championnat de
voltige et les ordres de passage un
tirage au sort moi je ne maîtrise pas le
hasard je peux pas maîtriser le temps
qui va faire le lendemain je peux
m'adapter éventuellement je peux
connaître un peu la météo mais ça après
voilà je peux pas maîtriser non plus mon
stress face à des échéances importantes
c'est normal d'avoir du stress c'est
peut pas faire contre par contre on
l'acceptent stress un cadeau c'est notre
organisme qui nous préparent à agir si
on canalise bien c'est plutôt quelque
chose de positif que quelque chose qui
va nous nous couler enfin ça arrive à la
troisième notion qui est le détachement
apprendre à se détacher de l'enjeu du
résultat du jugement de son jugement
propres
l'idée c'est vraiment de laisser libre
cours notamment et ben à toutes ses
compétences et ses automatismes
beaucoup de sportifs vont vous parler
quand ils ont réalisé une performance
ils vont dire ah je me sentais bien
j'avais les bonnes sensations j'étais
dans la zone étaient dans la fluidité
fluidité performance voilà il ya plein
de termes c'est ça finalement ça avoir
confiance en ses capacités
concrètement moi quand je suis en face
de vous là je suis déjà dans une
certaine forme de lâcher prise
c'est à dire que j'ai préparé j'ai
préparé ma présentation
je me suis entraîné devant ma glace des
centaines de fois fin surtout avec mon
coach didier mais là maintenant ici
présents moi je suis juste focaliser sur
le message que j'essaie de vous faire de
vous délivrer de faire passer au mieux
et j'accepte que parmi vous dans la
salle ya peut-être des gens qui n'ont
pas du tout adhéré à ce que j mais ça je
le maîtrise pas pour vous en général
finalement c'est quoi c'est lorsque vous
devez faire face à une échéance
importante
là où aller voir de l'action des
décisions et bien déjà il ya un précepte
à tout ça c'est de se préparer je suis
pas en train de vous dire allez-y la
fleur au fusil un championnat du monde
j'y suis pas allé sans avoir volé sans
m'être préparé
c'est quelque chose que le un sujet que
je ne maîtrise pas si j'y vais les mains
dans les poches ça ne marche pas ça de
suite on oublie par contre une fois au
moment d'agir moment d'être de réaliser
son action et bien c'est d'être
convaincu que finalement le résultat
final c'est de s'en détacher mais c'est
que ce qui va compter c'est la qualité
du travail qu'on va fournir sur le
moment et rien de plus et ça tombe bien
parce que vous êtes entraîné là dessus
pas sur le reste
donc il faut vraiment rester focalisé là
dessus
le management aussi le management ça
autorise aussi une certaine forme de
lâcher prise
lorsque vous travaillez avec une équipe
qui est bien entraînés bien formés c'est
accepter accepter que vous ne pourrez
pas avoir la main le contrôle sur tout
le monde c'est normal sinon vous risquez
de brider le potentiel global du groupe
finalement c'est plus agir comme un chef
d'orchestre un chef d'orchestre qui va
avoir ses musiciens chaque musicien
c'est exactement ce qu'il a à jouer
et vous en agissant ainsi vous allez
pouvoir prendre du recul finalement
revenir la tâche principale qui est
d'accorder l'ensemble d'accorder votre
orchestre de lui l'idée mais aussi
d'avoir le recul nécessaire pour par
contre là prendre les bonnes décisions
au bon moment et pas avoir la tête dans
le mur
je vais pas m'étendre sur le sujet du
leadership et du lâcher enfin du
leadership et du management parce que
c'est un vaste sujet également je pense
que on pourrait consacrer une édition
tedx entière là dessus mais juste pour
vous dire que finalement on peut
introduire ces notions à différents
niveaux
et puis comme on dit charité bien
ordonnée ça commence par soi même parce
que ces changements ils viendront pas
des autres qui viendront de vous c'est
vous qui allez vouloir évoluer et comme
toute évolution là ça demande de
l'entraînement ça demande de
l'entraînement et d'ailleurs c'est
paradoxal c'est s'entraîner à se
détacher finalement c'est faire pour
apprendre à se défaire de quelque chose
pourquoi parce que c'est comme tout le
reste c'est comme une habilité physique
au départ bas quand on le fait on a du
mal et puis plus de papier ça devient
très naturelle à nous notre cerveau
comme je vous disais et pas modeler pour
travailler comme ça depuis tout jeune on
est vraiment habitué à travailler plutôt
de manière compétitive donc pour évoluer
il va falloir un petit peu s'entraîner
puis au départ ce qui paraît difficile
va devenir de plus en plus naturel pour
ça il existe tout un tas de pratiquer
d'exercices connaissez la peut-être la
méditation la préparation mentale c'est
pas pour rien que maintenant la plupart
des sportifs de haut niveau et ont
recours on retrouve même dans le monde
de l'entreprise dans les grandes
sociétés ont fait de plus en plus appel
à des préparateurs mentaux pour préparer
les gens même au sein de l'armée on
utilise ce qu'on appelle les techniques
d'optimisation du potentiel et ça
concerne pas forcément que les pilotes
les commandos les contrôleurs enfin
voila c'est des techniques qui sont
empreints du sport de haut niveau on les
applique à différents domaines
et ça fonctionne tout ça pour rebondir
et conclure sur la phrase du début où je
vous disais bon je suis devenu champion
du monde à partir du moment où j'ai
cessé de vouloir l'être absolument je
pense que vous avez compris le message
enfin j'espère c'est l'idée ce n'est pas
de ne pas avoir d'objectif bien au
contraire
c'est d'aborder d'avoir toutes les
bonnes stratégies finalement pour
pouvoir l'atteindre
effectivement cette notion de prendre du
recul de prendre du lâcher prise dessus
ça en fait partie et donc il maintenant
il est peut-être temps pour vous aussi
et bien de cesser de vouloir absolument
obtenir à tout prix ce que vous voulez
pour augmenter vos chances de la voir
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]